it's harry but this is this is a very
dirty harry this one
this is not this is not a happy harry
this is a dirty harry
this is one of why are you looking at me
son this is this is this is oh my god
the accelerated harry attack
gosh this is actually the yeah time
we've ever caught a move like this yeah
we see it happen on other boards or we
see one c3 one d3 the boring stuff no h4
now and
what is that white pawn doing out on h4
it makes no sense it doesn't fight for
the center it doesn't improve the
development of the white pieces
i don't really know if i'm loving it or
not but it's i've played this in blitz
obviously and it's a load of rubbish
it's a terrible move we have the harry
attack against the queen's gambit it's
the queen's gambit with reverse colors
and magnus has declined the gambit
wow i mean
this is basically a normal position with
colours reversed except white has that
one extra move h4 and it if anything it
worsens the position white's king is
never going to be safe castling on this
side of the board anymore i mean i'm
trying to figure out like what are the
worst moves that white can play and move
one and i'd say like
h4 is probably the third
so i've got f3 knight h3 maybe h4 but
okay i mean he's now going into a tower
so he's got to make h4 work this is the
thing he's got to try to think of an
opening variation that he would normally
play with black and make that harry porn
fit into it because as david says you
know pushing a pawn they can't go
backwards and you weaken squares
especially the square next to harry
there that light square next strip but
um what a way to start the game i mean
pushing that pawn with like you know
what i mean what lunatic
you know we talked about like magnus
being just crazy making this uh dirty
dirty move but then just take a look at
way ye
he looks like it's yeah just another day
at the office
i'm not bothered i'm not surprised by
this at this point it's no longer
surprised that magnus kind of digs deep
into his bag of tricks and just plucks
out the weirdest move his opponents are
beginning to expect this i think the
bigger shock would be magnus playing a
normal opening at this point
and uh i think the most
kind of
surprising thing
out of all of these surprises is that
magnus he actually studies these types
of moves when he played one f3 against
duda last month
he had analyzed some opening theory he'd
worked out what he wanted to do against
black's most obvious moves and he's
clearly done the same again he's gained
20 seconds from when he started uh this
game and
he's taking he's taking chess in new
directions
but you know something you know you know
the quiz of the day is what is your
chest level and uh by opening up with
that first move you often see this as
the first move that a beginner who
hasn't seen the board before
nice get the rooks out get the rooks out
yeah that's that's the only theory that
i know yeah i mean if you if you showed
anyone this guess the elo kind of thing
it would be like it's probably about 300
euros
that's quite a fun game that i noticed a
lot of streamers play nowadays they put
they ask one of their viewers to kind of
show them a game and they'll try and
guess the elo and right yeah if you show
them this position i would say yeah
maximum
yeah fourteen hundred yeah yeah
uh
that rating definitely no
i i just saw um an answer to our quiz of
the day which i thought i have to share
with you especially in light of this and
uh it's uh from cancel who says that
their chess level is like drunk daniel
dubov fireworks aggression terrible
blunders and brilliant moves of course
the key is to have fun
i love that drunk duboff and uh
okay
well
very sensible very classical play it's
almost like uh where he is like well i'm
just going to forget about harry yeah
he's just going to keep his cool but
talking about harry how is how is harry
looking right now starting to look away
very lonely over there okay so put me
back where i came from please you know i
mean
it doesn't look so stupid actually if
you get what we call an isolated pawn
position the pawn the harry porn over is
very useful in certain positions but
you've now got to really take it into
this is where you're really going to be
an artist because you've got to direct
the the middle game position where that
pawn looks sensible and not stupid so
it's uh it can be yeah i mean with his
experience he can do that
i mean it's kind of terrible though you
know showing this to kids out there
there might be a lot of kids watching
this you know it's like showing them a
naughty video or something isn't it
that's why it's the last game of the day
it's the last game it's like it's like
you're asleep i know yeah the kids
hopefully they're all asleep because you
show this to someone who's trying to
learn chess you know and it's like oh my
words you know magnus cast is pushing h4
i'm going to play like this no don't
don't don't play like this you know
it's not good claire did ask me she said
uh
is magnus a
good role model just a couple of days
ago and definitely not in this game but
uh you know it's fun it's fun isn't it
we love it that's why we love it i mean
he's he's pretty much secure at this
point we see above magnus there he's got
22 points he's pretty much guaranteed to
get through to the um to the knockout
stages so why not enjoy the chess and uh
okay imagine how incredible it would be
if white h-born ends up winning the day
with some attack or by promoting
uh harry can become harriet become a
queen and
win the game who knows
yeah no
somehow i don't
i don't know but then where you would be
like i'm the person
that lost to
one
yeah
that's the annoying thing isn't it you i
mean you've got to you've got to forget
about that right you don't want to lose
to a ridiculous move and be remembered
as that person so maybe this is a bit of
a psychological ploy against the chinese
camp in case dingler qualifies it's like
i can beat you of h4 they're going to be
thinking oh no you know so if ding
qualifies for a world championship match
against magnus yeah imagine the ding
camp studying one h4 i mean come on yeah
they can't do that but now it looks like
no no no it's okay no it's not a problem
because the queens are off the board and
well magnus is uh working his magic he's
gotten away with it but i remember
magnus in the in the masters last month
starting out with one f3
then then h4 seems quite sane doesn't it
yeah
that's why i was trying to work out what
the worst moves white can play and
magnus is fine to them i don't need to i
don't need to worry about it you know
magnus is finding all the worst moves
just ahead of the chessball masters i
had a chat with magnus about the
worst first moves he said i think
according to the computer actually the
grub one g4 is the worst oh really or
alongside he hasn't played that yet has
he so he hasn't played one g4 yet this
is a one stretch too far maybe even for
magnus maybe we can jump in to show
what's happened because there have been
a lot of uh
differences so this is the current
position and if we just backtrack a few
moves ago here where he had a big
decision to make um here i think if he
was trying to punish magnus's 1h4 push
then he would have uh kind of refrained
from any trades he would have for
example castle the black king but now
the question is maybe this pawn push
becomes relevant maybe the white pawn
can go forward and uh destabilize the
black king position maybe the white rook
can even kind of come and swing across
later on so wei yi said okay no more fun
for you magnus we're to grind it out in
an end game and if we backtrack instead
of castling he played pawn takes pawn
allowing this queen trade and uh if we
fast forward to the current position
it's actually very symmetrical right now
these pawns are completely balanced by
white pawns
white maybe has slightly better bishops
that's the one difference in this
position
white's bishops kind of look very nicely
along these diagonals meanwhile the
black bishops are still stuck at home
but other than that everything is
balanced and as simon said this white h
pawn it doesn't look too great too bad
it cramps black i mean when i've played
one h4 online i've had on like you know
i've had messages coming back at me like
you [ __ ] give me some respect and uh
you know that's the kind of message i
get but magnus can get away with it but
it looks kind of sensible you banker
right yeah i was going to say actually
you know after laughing at the first
move
i really like magnus's position you know
david mentioned that the bishop's better
but i'm actually going to say there's
another piece that i think is better and
that is why it's night that is that's
that that's stuck there on a starting
square because that knight can actually
go to
via the d2 square by the b and jump onto
the b3 square yep just to show that
night's path the black knight
this is the dream destination for white
tonight the black knight meanwhile looks
nice but can't jump anywhere and the
journey has started black castle the
king and ivanka you've highlighted this
already the white knight is gonna jump
to b3 and then into a nice outpost and
the reason this is a better square than
black's knight sits on it's because it's
anchored by a pawn and black cannot
challenge for the rights to the square
so
yeah really i mean uh it's small margins
here it should be balanced because the
pawn structure is completely symmetrical
queens are off um it should be a draw
with best player of course the same game
but magnus is a master in end games and
if for example black is just slow and
allows this white knight into the
position then this knight is going to
dominate proceedings
so a clear plan for white not so clear
for black also i'm slightly surprised in
the current position that black has
castled as king when queens are off
kings don't necessarily need to be
tucked away in the corner white's king
is much more flexible white's king has a
nice home just one square
forward and if it comes down to lots of
exchanges a porn race for example
white's king is better placed in the
middle of the board than black's king
off on one side so
the black bishop comes back and now uh
i'm expecting the white king to step
forward freeing up this white rook uh
maybe the white knight as ivanka
mentioned will okay there we go the
white king does step forward the white
knight will park itself on this square
later on i love the messages i i
sometimes have a little look at chess 24
chat and you know some messages like did
magnus really start with h4 it must be a
transmission error you know this kind
this is the kind of general theme when a
move like this is playing he started
with one h4 maybe he's the only i don't
know any super grand master to ever ever
have played this in a tournament a
serious game against a serious opponent
yeah against a very good point but his
position looks quite quite nice right
you couldn't have asked for a better
opening position than this
i would have said earlier that wei yi is
one of the few that wouldn't be kind of
perturbed or just kind of annoyed
psychologically about facing a move like
that one but the way he's played it he's
given magnus way too much respect
if your opponent plays h4 you've got to
try and punish them yeah but definitely
no he's uh now just gonna get ground
down in an end game potentially or maybe
wei will hold this game
push it towards a draw great result but
against one h4 i think more than that i
think one e5 must be a better move
against one h4 i'm just thinking about
openings you know one e5 because one e5
is much more one e4 is much more testing
so one e5 must be a much more testing
move just in case you want to get your
theory on the harry the dirty harry
attack ready or whatever so it's
actually a course by um another great
author christoph solecki uh he's he's
done a course called the dirty i think
it's called the dirty harry it's not on
this move because that would just be a
bit too outrageous but it's on a line
in the sicilian which uh so it's already
been coined that phrase yeah
gosh no i really like what magnus is
doing and simon earlier on you asked
about chess tattoos
i did you did and uh drunk yoda obliged
and says look look at their chest tattoo
it's very very cool okay drunk yoda okay
i have to say i'm really impressed with
everyone's chest or tubes okay guys i've
got to like zoom in on that one somehow
so uh we'll see if it comes up okay yeah
yeah that's quite cool it is like a fun
funky night it's like a viking kind of
insignia is this really it looks like a
funky night on a leg is that right i
like it i like it nice nice nice work
drunk yoda i was wondering if it was
just yoda prior to getting that tattoo
and then it changed his neck afterwards
and
i also you know we do have our quiz of
the day where we're asking what is your
chest level and there's a tremendous
prize up for grabs and it's gwen jones
lifetime repertoire on the kings indian
and uh robert ball says uh
chess level
superhero
captain blunder i like it but obviously
not the blundering part but i like the
kind of tweet
nice answer and if you two want to have
a chance at winning
gawain jones chessable course on the
kings indian then remember to tweet your
answer using the hashtag chesschamps
yeah and the more i look at it the more
i think magnus has very good chances in
this endgame also look at the clock
times
yes magnus played a weird first move but
with it he has gained a seven and a half
minute time advantage
one move
for that amount of time in a rapid game
it's definitely worth it i think wei yi
here
maybe he's keeping a poker face but
maybe just
uh just a bit stressed a bit worried now
about the potential of losing to one h4
and he's he's also i think has he lost
every game today i mean i mean if he
hasn't lost every game he's had a really
bad day so he's already on there the
down downward spiral and one drawn two
losses today so i mean that's really you
know and then if you lose against one h4
you're like oh my god why am i playing
chess anymore it's like you know this is
no fun for the first time
ever we've seen where you slightly shake
his head there emotion yeah yeah and uh
yeah i mean i think i saw those stats
just before the event and he had what
was it 98 99 chance of qualifying before
today if he loses this game he's going
to be starting to look over his shoulder
he still needs a win or two maybe to
kind of lock it down and get into those
knockouts
okay meanwhile we spending a long long
time but playing a very natural move
bringing the black rook across now the
all the rooks are kind of looking at
each other a bit of symmetry there
before the rooks disappear i think black
will be much happier but again it's the
position of the kings it's the position
of the bishops i think white's king is
better than the black king white's
bishops are better than the black
bishops and ivanka mentioned the white
knight maybe on a better circuit than
its counterpart as well yeah this night
looks key uh in the long run doesn't it
i mean uh it's just a little bit better
for white isn't it and that's what
magnus wants he wants a position which
is a little bit better and i have to say
something you know about this position
there's a lot of you can get a lot of
pattern recognition from other openings
where you see this is very similar and
as dave is highlighting the knight is
going to go to c5 square and then put
pressure and suddenly the advantage
becomes slightly more it may be it's the
bishop pair and then it will be maybe
better rooks and then it becomes like a
small you're collecting those little
tiny advantages and together they make
something big yeah and now the black
knights dropped back and here i was
going to say maybe there's a few plans
for white one could be maybe going on
the attack bring the white knight
forward attacking this pawn one could be
maybe a long-term positional uh thing
and this is one thing that um simon our
friend keith arkell would love to do
push his pawns forward
in an end game just trying to clamp down
on squares trying to gain some space and
again just looks
slightly not much but slightly better
for white white is definitely the more
flexible of the two it all depends on
whether black at some point can push his
pawn forward and just eliminate one half
of the board trade everything off if he
can maybe he'll draw i think we know
what those inside videos on chess 24
were now looking at in preparation for
the world championships they were
obviously studying this one h4 move
weren't they they must have spent at
least a week there probably with quite a
lot of alcohol i'd imagine if they were
gonna come and look at that move but uh
no i mean this is just not the move you
look at and what you know for something
like that but it's if it was the idea of
anyone in the magnus training camp whose
idea do you think it was well it would
have been a drunk jordan i don't know or
maybe a duboff i don't know yorder or
duval
no you don't think young gustafson i can
imagine him going yeah why not
it could be as well as a joke maybe yeah
but peter heiner would be like if you
play that i'm never going to be your
coach again you know because i reckon
but magnus after playing one f3 in in
the previous tournament he came out for
an interview where he told me that yeah
actually we actually did some lines on
this and i had the preparation go in and
it was uh starting out well i
unfortunately forgot the rest of it but
he had actually prepared seriously for
one f3 see david was saying that but i
don't know i don't think so i don't know
if hopefully
is that true i i mean it was obvious
in the game okay because four moves
later he was at least equal maybe even
better as white imagine afterwards he's
done the same here yeah so i mean
yeah you mean
i mean you play you're playing so speed
with which she played uh he actually
told me afterwards he was like okay
these two three lines white is not lost
but much much worse uh big disadvantage
but uh it's not easy for the opponents
wei yi has never studied one h4 i can
tell you that now judo has never studied
one f3 before that one day i can tell
you that
so
it's uh it's just mind games my games
chess is very rich
a whole variety of moves you can choose
from are you inspired david no
i would never touch this one even with
the barge pole but uh
hey the black bishop
that's a weird move the black bishop was
on this square what was it four moves
ago and uh it actually the black bishop
went from f8 to e7 to d8 to e7 to d8
it's like doing a bit of a yo-yo dance
this black bishop i really like your
night jump idea towards the king side
but
you know mainly the idea of bringing it
towards the center now uh something like
this we could maybe show it on the
analysis board
it just seems like white has better
pieces but this idea david pointed out
uh it creates a threat against the pawn
and let's just say uh black defends that
threat by moving it or something the
main idea is to centralize the night
right when there's some really nice
outpost
for that night to come into which can't
be guarded by a black pawn
very simple
very simple idea very simple i mean i
think this one's definitely on magnus's
radar um also moving the rook makes a
lot of sense i'm not sure which square
maybe this one maybe this one um i do
notice the undefended knight here that's
why magnus actually shifts his rook the
whole way across and now there is a bit
of a small threat here if uh okay ding
defends his knight which is undefended
if he just moved his bishop for example
then white can play bishop takes pawn
check throwing the bishop out the way
gaining a pawn in the process and now
he's unleashed his rook with a
discovered attack to capture this black
knight so that's a devastating threat
ding did defend against it uh he pushed
his rook forward one square defending
this knight defending its bishop but
i'm just asking myself what is this
bishop doing why did he retreat it to
the square last move he's blocked it in
strange stuff from wagy
but there's there's so many pieces left
on the board there's so many
complications left and if you're looking
at at the time this is this is not
voting well here time wise for why years
it's him
it's not at all no i mean the time is
bad and he's under a lot of pressure i
mean he's put all his pieces on that
left-hand side of the board and they're
just getting in the way of each other
magnus has created even a threat with
his last move to win material if he just
starts swapping things and
you know they're discombobulated i
haven't got that word in yet and i'm
really happy to get it
it's my favorite word discombobulated i
i love it uh everyone's got a does
everyone have a favorite word i don't
know do you have a favorite word
everyone's going to be on google right
now searching what discombobulate means
it just sounds nice doesn't it like
discombobulated it's like onomatopoeia
it sounds like what it is so i don't
know but any favorite words cellador
cellador have you ever have thought
about it it's actually just a door for a
seller but it sounds like it taken out
of a tolkien novel it's like selador
exactly or it could be like a you know
like an area couldn't it celador
go to the mythical range of cellador
yeah it's nice i like it actually yeah
it's like whole door isn't there whole
door
oh yeah yeah that was that was from the
game of thrones i think so yeah david
you got a freight word i've literally
never thought of this
on the spot now checkmate study english
literature yeah yeah you've got very
good uh my favorite expression which is
kind of borrowed from the lord of the
rings is when you're trying to set up a
fortress and you're gonna like you shall
not pass
and it's like the gandalf approach yeah
you know and uh i actually got it from
some scottish friends and they were like
yeah you know she played the gowned
gandalf approach and i was like what was
that
i was like okay
very ambitious then i'm guessing that
the only one who wants us to go into
lord of the rings analogy right now is
nakamura and it's not playing
mike this is sauron
and it's funny i mean nakamura
kind of posted this tweet about how
magnus is sauron he's the only one who
can stop him and that was years ago and
for a while it looked like he would
never challenge magnus again but now
he's in the candidates maybe we'll see
nakamura against sauron
who knows it was a bit of a joke right
you know because he he said that are
they all those things but then when they
you the statistics really did not bear
any resemblance to nakamura's claims it
was like a heavy
heavy result for magnus he posted that
and then he lost the next several games
to magnus uh over the board so
but if if we spin on that though i'm
curious what you guys are thinking
because i know a lot of viewers back
home probably think that magnus's claims
about not playing another world
championship is complete bogus obviously
i the way he talks about it it sounds
like he's very sincere about the option
of not defending his title do you think
nakamura is a guy who could
instill some
excitement and some fun in that in that
matchup i think that's one way to
guarantee magnus playing the world if
nakamura wins the candidates because he
he doesn't want him to be world champion
he he's not step aside for nakamura
i think he might be right there actually
i think he's like he cannot allow
nakamura to be world champion he's like
that's one guy
yeah but do you think that magnus will
be willingly
willing to kind of step aside for anyone
i i i mean i think it's an option i
don't think he has to play i don't see
why he should i cannot imagine that but
then his life he can make his own
decisions and if he thinks it's best for
him then i agree in principle with that
but then this the reality is is that
someone else by default is going to
become world champion right so that
might be a difficult pill to swallow
yeah i don't know what's going to happen
when it gets to be very interesting i
mean maybe it's uh i mean i can i also
think it's more likely he will uh play
for the world championships but
it's finishing on the top isn't it as
well you don't you know how long will he
play for he doesn't want to play for
another 20 years does he lose the world
championship so
it's it's yeah it's really hard i don't
know it's very strange very strange you
know i don't know any other world
champions who have ever done that has
there been fisher maybe yeah yeah fisher
yeah of course yeah but what is also
strange about it is the fact that he
said he doesn't want to quit playing
chess he wants to reach
2 900 he wants to reach for the
unattainable but he just
to put it simply or to put it in
straight terms he's quite bored with the
extreme preparations necessary to play a
world championship match in the current
format and you can see it in this game
right you can see that he's having fun
yeah you know in this game when he plays
their free there's not any preparation
he's enjoying himself but when he plays
the world championships you have to do
months of work on
stuff maybe you don't want to work on so
you have to do that again so yeah so it
it's it's
maybe they need to change the format
then the world championships somehow
it's it's
i don't know david i mean you know you
probably know him the best out of all of
us and i you know what are your thoughts
on on the matter as well i hope he'll
play i mean yeah yeah it's it's a hard
one he's serious right now about not
playing that's all i know yeah um but
yeah we'll see a few months a lot could
change and candidates next month is
going to be super exciting
nakamura would be cool i think that
would be match of the century carlson
against nakamura imagine the press i
think it'd be great for chess as well
having an american
you know this very popular chess over
there they've got lots of money in the
game having an american fight like
fisher for the world championships would
be good for chess and having that
rivalry would be great as well so i
think that'd be that'd be it would be a
good world championships definitely and
as we've seen on the tour before as well
nakamura can push carson to the limit
it's not a full conclusion even if that
does happen
uh so yeah i mean while there have been
a few moves in this game maybe we can
jump in because magnus has been thinking
for a long time and i don't feel he's
got maybe he's still good for white but
he hasn't found the winning blow and it
was in this position where white is
actually threatening to win material as
simon pointed out for example if black
just plays a quiet move white can just
trade everything off white can actually
give up one of his rooks for two pieces
here he can remove black's bishop from
the board and win black's knight at the
end it's important that white's rook can
actually come back and block any attack
we would see in a situation like this
two knights against one black rook
and uh magnus would have all the chances
two knights two pieces are better than
one but we spotted that threat he
brought his
knight to attack this white bishop and
after this knight was captured he took
back with a pawn and i think that's for
two reasons black yes he's worse than
his pawn structure but at least the
black king now has a safe square he's
not going to get checkmated on the back
rank the black king has some breathing
space but also for example i thought
that this white knight jump was very
strong at first i thought it was almost
winning but the black pawn now can step
forward and challenge this white bishop
and it's less clear than it should be
suddenly personally i don't see a way
forward for white maybe you have to take
a step back with your bishop you're
still doing well because you have this
really really monstrous strong knight
but what's going to say it's back by
myself this will play g4 you know
because this is just magnus isn't it he
sees his opponent's idea stops it yeah
it keeps the frets alive yeah
black wants to push this pawn so why not
push and cover this square now this is a
monstrous threat now uh the white knight
jumping in a winning threat for magnus
if he can achieve it because if he
eliminates this bishop then he
eliminates the defender of this black
knight and the black rook has had to
swing across if the white knight jumps
in now then i think there might be some
tricks involved um i think uh wei is
looking down at this white rook and for
example after knight takes pawn he has a
nasty pin along this line and he
actually wins material so
it's tactical it might be an end game
but it is full of tricks white's desired
move doesn't quite work yet
and maybe where he's hanging on for now
still looks good for white though
he still looks great for white but uh
definitely there's some tricks in the
air and this is one thing i noticed with
wei you know i had personal experience
of playing him he is tactically sharp
yeah and
i heard a lot of the chinese players
actually they learnt chinese chess first
they learn chinese chess where it's all
about two three move tactics pretty much
that's how you win the game two or three
move tactics here and there's all about
calculation and then if they learn kind
of classical chess the chess we know
after then they can use those skills
that's why they're so tactically sharp
so young
and
i think i heard that about wei yi years
and years ago but
yeah he's a tactician for sure and
magnus
had a six seven minute time advantage
that's starting to disappear
maybe he's frustrated he can't find the
winning blow there's also pressure on
magnus he wants to play h4 and win right
he doesn't want to play h4 and lose and
for there to be jokes about that for
years
magnus wants to
seize the moment this is probably the
best position he could ever hope for
from one h4
and talking about terrible opening moves
we have a tweet from elmer johnson who
says that the worst first move has to be
and he says the uh sodium attack do you
guys know what the sodium attack is one
knight a
a3 is it a three yeah why it's called
the sodium attack yeah
because yeah it says in the tweet it
gives the game away because n a is the
name of sodium yeah i think it's not as
bad as night h3 though but um yeah
anyway actual i'll give you a fun fact
that elmer shared with me as well here
earlier he's saying that uh eminem
released a song called discombobulated
in 2020. so you're on the you're on the
hip-hop type the white vibe today i am
yeah i didn't even realize actually
she's pretty bad so yeah yeah well i
have to listen to that song i used to
like myself a little bit of m m so who
doesn't it's a good uh
warm-up music um
wow magnus doing what magnus loves best
you know he loves to do he just pushes
that
he pushes that pawn
harry or one square forward and takes as
much space as possible and this is
something we've seen with magnus you
know he's kind of got
i i liked carl portman's uh expression
helicopter vision you know it's all over
the board you know he's like expanding
taking small advantages here and there
and uh he was discussing this morning
and we were talking about jurassic park
and our favorite scenes
and
he was saying he was telling me that his
favorite scene in jurassic park is when
the hunter is hunting the velociraptor
and uh
he's gonna shoot it and another one
comes over from the side and it's like
oh good girl
and then he gets killed
i just wanted to add one little thing
here prior to taking this move by way
and that's the fact that the comeback
player of the day
uh like we had jordan yesterday today it
has to be ariane thori he won his third
game in a row he's now up to 15 points
he looked like he was dead out of the
water in this
in this tournament right now prior to
the other games ending he's on equal
points as the seventh and eighth place
wow that's brilliant what what a day so
he's back in the running yeah yeah great
great news and i think we learned in
previous events uh earlier this season
that normally the magic number is around
21 22. if you can get that you've pretty
much secured your place in the uh in the
knockouts in the quarterfinals
and uh meanwhile there was a move it
white played h4 on move one pushing
harry up the board it took him 21 more
moves to push his h1 up again and uh
where he said you're going no further
that black pawn has blocked the advance
of harry
and uh yeah status quo is still
maintained it looks so good for white
white has the better pawn structure
black has those doubled f pawns remember
white has all the pressure white's rooks
looking up the board white's knights are
ready to jump in but
for now it's holding together i don't
see anything direct
and i think that's frustrating for
magnus wei yi the last few moves i think
he's defended really really well
yeah there's no no obvious way and he's
relying on these little tactics to stop
that big night coming in i mean
i guess if there's nothing immediate um
white should think about maneuvering his
worst pieces to better squares i mean
this is just a standard way to think
about a middle game position often you
know players think okay i don't know
what to do in the middle game this is a
middle game even though the queens are
off look at your pieces which are good
you don't need to move them look at your
pieces which are bad so i'd be looking
at the white knight by the king um maybe
we could just highlight that david and
i'd just be thinking okay it might look
like a good an okay piece but
it's not doing a great deal maybe i
could even bring it back and try to
target some weak squares in the long run
so this would just be a quite a i say
lazy way to play i was even thinking
going to e1 yeah me too and bringing it
around to the big weakness we've we've
uh talked about before maybe just
something like this is a sensible way to
look okay you have to watch out for some
tactics but
um it it defends the rook as well so
exactly yeah so it was like a
multi-purpose move yeah you're getting
my vote already simon looks very logical
doesn't it just to defend the rook so
maybe your other knight can jump in but
just improve it and he's gone for
david's move of course
i mean the reason i was more attracted
to this one first is because i thought
it was maybe more urgent to protect this
bishop there's a few lines with uh where
this bishop is a bit loose and i just
you know me uh ivanka i know you've
mentioned this before when i'm low on
time low on the clock i just want to
defend every piece so actually
this one wasn't really on my radar i
liked it as soon as you said it but uh
magnus choosing the other route uh at
least now he defends his other knight he
defends his bishop just in case for
example there was a knight check black
giving up a knight jumping into the
middle of the board for example white
recaptures suddenly this bishop it looks
like black can take it but it is
defended by white's knight so after a
trade of rooks white can win this piece
back white wins material so magnus just
with this night move keeping everything
protected
just good rapid chest strategy i think
and
the onus is on wei yi again i think
magnus is just saying okay here's the
move i'm throwing it back to you you've
got two minutes what are you going to do
it's very hard for black to move right
and and again like black's got all his
pieces huddled over there but what can
black do i mean he how does he break out
that how does he do anything here and i
can't really see maybe he doesn't he
takes a leaf out of the book of the art
of doing nothing and oh our favorite
book yeah
promise
he's done something he jumps in with his
knight into the center but i was going
to say he couldn't just wait and sit and
do nothing because every move he had to
calculate white's knight jumping in now
we see a trade of rooks
and uh he did decide to do something
he's happy now if the light squared
bishop's come off
he's just trying to
kind of free up his position with the
exchanges and this wouldn't have been
possible actually if
magnus had used the the square for the
white knight that you wanted simon yeah
white's knight now in the middle of the
board blocks the white rook and there we
go magnus trading off a set of knights
the knights are definitely going to
leave the board now because white's rook
is also attacking the black bishop at
the top
so black's bishop needs to move or be
defended this is one case where the
white knight is is going to be stronger
than the black bishop because again
throughout the whole game that white
knight has this beautiful square you
know once once the pair of knights get
exchanged you'll have a position knight
versus bishop and uh you know sometimes
the knight can be better than the bishop
and in this case it's that white knight
on the left-hand side of the board it
can jump into uh into the game and
target black's pawn so it is it's a
magnus position still isn't it i mean
he's going to really be enjoying this
yeah maybe there's something better more
direct but magnus has steered the game
into a situation where he knows there's
almost zero risk at this point for white
and he still has weaknesses to to nibble
at in black's camp that black a6 pawn
i'm looking at it
it's very weak it white's rook is going
to come up to the sixth rank maybe and
target it uh black has doubled pawns
weaknesses on both sides of the board
and
yeah knights are super tricky in these
types of positions you can just see
where he is not happy and also he's
coming to just under a minute on the
clock
and uh he's moved his bishop and i have
to say i think magnus has played a
really flawless game it's been
incredibly
instructive are really controlled yeah
definitely i mean like david said maybe
there was something stronger but he's
controlled it right and he's done
everything his way so far so he's uh got
the position he wants he's pushing a
little bit
yeah yeah totally easy and you have to
bear in mind that way he is an
incredibly strong player yeah and to do
this to him
without too much effort
it's a way to play the future of chess
such a bad influence for the young
generation i know this is the thing you
know you're gonna have to show this game
there's gonna be like you know loads of
youtube videos coming by all the people
saying magnus wins of h4 all these kids
are gonna tune into the channel oh my
words h4 this is my secret opening and
they're all gonna start playing it and
it's gonna be a disaster if russ simon
i don't think that they will be doing it
i think most people will go very good
magnus very good but we'll leave that
kind of stuff to you and now if let's do
a comparison of all the pieces it's
level material actually on the board but
the reason white is winning and you see
the evaluation bar so far in white's
favor is because white's rook is better
than the black rook black's rook is
stuck just doing a defensive job white's
knight has more potential than the black
bishop white's knight any moment we can
jump in we've highlighted a few squares
the white knight will use at the moment
it's sitting nice and pretty staying
flexible but also compare the kings
magnus's last move the white king is
getting ready to enter the center it's
going to go towards the middle of the
board where black has doubled pawns the
black king meanwhile stuck a bit offside
not really able to participate so
all of those small things they do add up
also the clock that's another maybe the
fourth advantage for white um having
extra three minutes in a position like
this when you are the one pressing your
opponent is defending defending a
position like this is torture no time
especially against the world champion
and i understand black's last move you
want to exchange pawns off try to try to
swap down at least with that last move
he's
maybe going to push his push pushes pawn
and try to do that yeah do you want to
know the path of this bishop uh simon
it started on the f8 square it went to
e7 it went to d8 then next it went back
to e7 then it went back to d8 then again
it went back to e7 back to d8 this is
the third time this bishop has sat on
this square
and meanwhile yes he's supporting this
pawn push using his bishop but the white
king has indeed centralized itself this
pawn is now a big target it's up for
grabs
i mean is it now time for where you just
to break out push the porn must be time
because otherwise he's simply going to
get supplicated he's done it he's got
he's got to do this doesn't he you know
try to try to swap off and it's a good
strategy actually yeah abandoned pawns
pawns and less important in engage than
activity and he needed to free up his
rook free up his bishop so uh for
example if the white king takes this
pawn now then after a trailer pawns at
least this black rook is going to get in
the game for example it can drop down
start attacking summer white's pawns
it's not one-way traffic anymore so uh
still very very good for white it should
be
a position where he can maybe press for
a win but
ding i like his last couple of moves at
least the white knight jumps in now and
i think we'll see a trader pawns black's
rook needs to break free
uh like the queen song
i was thinking about two
can you sing it
one two break three there you go nice on
your anchor and then you go
17 seconds anyway we've got to head back
because it didn't have so much time and
uh well the rook is out it is out it's
broken free and uh well you know it's
threatening some pawns and uh this
should bring wei yi a little bit of joy
yeah and uh the clock situation is maybe
less important now because wei's few
moves they are pretty much forced uh
some of them he has to go active with
his rook he has to attack pawns if you
take a time out with black then white's
just gonna
kind of swarm all over you and take all
of your pawns so um this move very very
important the rook has broken free on
the second rank that's where a lot of
targets will lie
magnus is he gonna jump back with his
knight maybe protect that white pawn on
the f2 square is he gonna push that
attacked pawn forward one
uh one square
okay magnus he's the one actually he
needs to be accurate because if wei yi
gets the opportunity to maybe trade the
black bishop for the white knight
good drawing chances
very good drawing chances here i like
what black's done i mean uh
it's a really tough position and
you never if you if you've got to well i
say never but you shouldn't try to
defend passively this is maybe the
biggest typical mistake that lower-rated
players played defending passively
clever move there from wei this is not
defending passively he's set up a big
threat uh and actually we have to show
this because now magnus has to be
careful there's a trap in the position
if magnus is careless after this rook
move then he will lose the protection of
his knight it looks like the knight is
nicely defended with his king but okay
he finds a safe move if magnus had been
greedy here and gone after some pawns
then black would actually throw his own
pawn forward distracting away the white
king the white king has to move away
from its knight and the white knight
drops suddenly black would be the one
playing for the win um so magnus forced
to defend passively we said that simon
it's not what he wants to do but just
what he has to do he drops his rook the
whole way back to hold on to his knight
and uh yes this pawn is still under fire
from white's king but suddenly white's
rook and knight on defensive squares
ding do uh sorry were ye doing a great
job yeah and he's doing it with uh not
that much time on the clock uh he made
that that move with just six seconds to
spare yeah not uh easy task at all yeah
but
what do you think about this move though
is slightly
i don't know what he's gonna do next
that's the problem i'm not sure where
his next move is
this move on his own may be okay but
what does he do next yeah i like
magnus's last move
white has to be slightly careful he
doesn't kind of self-checkmate the white
king has no escape squares really but
as you mentioned simon the black bishop
was stuck so it had to retreat can you
now take the okay this way and then take
the pawn with the knight next move would
be uh uh very off very shortly okay so
to calculate pretty well though
you have tricks here right because um
um
where you could actually move the rook
to the c2 square and uh thread and check
mate wow
[Laughter]
that'd be too tempting not to play
wouldn't it i mean especially in blitz
chess if black could pick up his rook
and put it on the c4 square that is
checkmate immediately
but unfortunately if the black rook
moves then the white knight is free and
okay maybe setting that up next movie
ivanka black first defends pawns with
his own king
well this one is getting let's get a
little bit a little bit possible
suddenly yeah hey magnus one pawn up but
we can threaten checkmate oh he's not
he's going oh
where's that king going does he just
want to free up the black f pawn to come
down a trick oh there's a trap there's a
huge trap he loves his traps doesn't he
he's setting all the traps for magnus
magnus now if he gets greedy i was going
to say he can win a second pawn but
suddenly the black pawn is going to come
down and this is checkmate white's king
we know what that pawn checkmate is
called look at this starfish evaluation
david and goliath wow there's only one
move for magnus otherwise magnus is
actually going to lose guys there's only
one move for magnus otherwise he's lost
okay he has to push his pawn forward
with a check right i think that's
very seeable very findable this move
because there is a pin along this line
but
it's just about ruling out the other
moves you can't move your knight we saw
that this pawn will come down with a
checkmate
and uh yeah okay he finds it magnus who
he has the advantage now the black king
however is getting active is taking some
pawns
so it's becoming a pawn race it ah is
magnus gonna be able to push his pawns
are those pawns gonna be sufficiently
fast that is the question black now has
some counter play and pawn takes pawn i
like this move now the white knight is
super safe no more checks and this black
bishop is running out of squares looking
good for carson again running out time
as well
yeah and i'm guessing that the
white rook now can start to activate
itself but wait you know he's still a
tricky customer because uh
the bishop can uh switch
diagonals and maybe start attacking the
weak e3 pawn yeah
i mean he set up two checkmating traps
he's set up traps to win the white
knight
i mean magnus he's we've seen a few
one-move blunders from him previous
uh in previous games and while another
one-move checkmate threat on the board
wants to bring his rook back to the c4
square on the fourth rank white's king
covers any potential checks be
horrendous facing
way ye when you've got no time at all
because he keeps setting up these
horrible little moves but he's playing
creative defense there though he is
great defense from wei i mean to get
this far i mean we thought it was a
tremendously difficult position but to
get this far
has uh almost been miraculous but
probably not amazing
five seconds take a move where you don't
have too much time in doubt take a pawn
with the black king okay he attacks this
white pawn uh with the black bishop now
black rook
but magnus he's gonna probably block it
with a knight yeah i think he can block
the black bishop with a knight now
magnus can bully wei with trades if the
knight and bishop come off the board
white is completely winning
uh so okay maybe is magnus going to move
his knight what else could he be looking
at maybe
yep it's on the board taking this knight
now would probably just lose for black
white has this b pawn that's why it
black had to go and keep an eye on it
it's not that easy to push it yet maybe
the white king at some point will just
walk over and guide it up the board
actually that looks like a good move
just bring the king over
yeah i bought that pawn thanks i love it
and teamwork makes the dream work
utilize every single piece you have and
what oh
no no no this was my first instinct but
then i changed my mind i wasn't sure
about this
okay
so he's taken a pawn magnus temporarily
was three pawns up but he's lost his
most valuable pawn that white b pawn was
surely destined to promote uh magnus has
given it away and he's tried to
calculate this one he's aiming for a
rook and pawn end game but
i don't like this practical decision for
magnus it's now purely a pawn race and
is white quick enough black is going to
create a past pawn of his own black's h
pawn he has a he has a trick up his
sleeve right he's going to
give a check i mean can black take the
pawn big question can black take the h
pawn yeah white's h pawn that he pushed
on move one is it about to fall off the
board
he takes it i
he had to calculate that but i think
this is what magnus has
had maybe
misjudged he thought maybe the white
rook could slide back two squares give a
check and slide across
we have to show this on the board right
now and
actually magnus still has chances to win
the computer thinks that magnus should
bring his rook across cut off this black
king cut off it uh its kind of attempts
to recentralize itself but maybe what
magnus has misjudged is that the white
rook cannot come back and stop this now
because after a trade of rooks i think
black is ju
just in time to push his pawn
even i'm not sure here it's been a long
day david i can't calculate these ones
at the moment white is making a queen
black is making a queen who knows but uh
okay i think magnus going away from that
uh option he is banking all on this pawn
now isn't this just a draw it looks like
a draw black is in time now yeah black
is just going to push this pawn and try
and self stalemate uh for example
oh i'm not okay the evaluation bar has
turned up black maybe it's one move too
uh too slow because after this move
simon white's rook can slide back
attacking this pawn and if the pawn
moves this again building a bridge we
call it blocking the black rook stopping
it from sacrificing itself for this pawn
and then uh this pawn just promotes it's
not just a draw is it no okay but maybe
you can actually check the timer look at
the time yeah yeah oh is he lost on time
two seconds left two seconds let's go
back to the players because it's just so
dramatic we will explain this end game
um a bit later when we get the result
but maybe magnus is just in time now
yeah i mean he is his king king can go
in front of the rook now
if it gets checked again it doesn't go
in front of the pawn it goes in front of
a rook i i hope i got this right
otherwise yes there you go yeah and uh
this is just
making a new queen and i think he's just
in time to win this one yeah um
the valuation bar changes wow
it's it's not i mean you still it's the
race
okay can white just block this with his
rook
but then
the king gets out of his change
ideally we need two three minutes to
just sit there calculate oh it's a porn
race white promotes black gives up his
rook for the pawn and then all is white
in time to stop the black pawn but
neither i mean we don't have them
we don't have time to show it maybe but
it is just calculation and
um i mean these these are these are
great training exercises positions like
this if you want to improve your
calculation don't necessarily have to
look at positions of lots of pieces on
the board look at positions like this
where you've got to work out can you
block with a rook and what happens then
if the black rook gives itself up for
the pawn because there's only one train
of variation and you have to visualize
that one variation as far ahead as
possible in more complex middle games
you have to visualize many
different variations i i find he's very
good for improving i think he's in time
actually as an example just to show
white can win the black rook at any
moment for the queen but it's all about
whether white can get back and stop this
pawn or whether it will cost white his
rook
so it's just a race magnus needs to
calculate is he quick enough to bring
back the white king in situations like
this he's only got one minute magnus
carlsen but does he for example now
block with the white rook does he run
away with his king
so many options that's the problem so
many options only one minute well yeah i
mean it's so complicated as well because
uh the white rook is always going to be
a very nuisance uh piece because it's
going to check the black king force it
back into the corner in situations like
this one uh just to show why i think
this is a draw for example yes you can
check but at the right moment um okay
it's just a race basically i think black
should go the other way i'm trying to
show your idea ivanko but um for example
if you check at the right time the black
king can actually hide in the corner and
try and stalemate itself quite often
so we have this position we're headed
towards this position
i think it's a technical draw that that
position you're showing david i think
it's most likely it's too slow but um
you know it's it's again down to half a
tempo
white needs to promote but he needs his
rook on this square to cut off the black
king from going towards the center you
need to keep the black king in front of
its own pawn if you want to win this
game
i have a feeling it's winning but it's
so hard to find
and okay magnus repeats the position
it's the second time we've seen this
position on the board if he moves his
rook across and if black does the same
then this would end up in a draw so he
okay
plays for the win
how is magnus gonna win this one how is
he gonna promote
he has to bring his king back now the
way um sorry the way it came from
he's gonna be really careful the
position is repeating itself this is the
second time we've seen this position as
well the king going back this way
is magnus maybe gonna try and snake his
king
i'm trying to say back but
i don't know how this helps
i do not know how this helps okay let's
see
magnus this is the most complicated end
game i've seen in a long time on the
champions chess tour
and okay the black brook goes away
i'm struggling yeah i mean
it's weird the computer assessment it
doesn't it it's not easy to evaluate if
this is a winner draw even with that
assessment because
uh you can't tweet us you can't see yeah
i mean you can get this on table base um
which is a thing that you can use which
will tell you um exactly what the
computer says because computers
and better ones than the one we're using
here and now magnus
under 20 seconds now they're going down
to 10 seconds
and
yeah i actually think it's just a draw
he has to perhaps go into this uh rook
versus pawn end game
and maybe a second i'm surprised they
haven't done free fall by now this
position actually the black rook
previously wasn't on the first rank yeah
like this has found a way to repeat but
yeah just trying to gain time on the
clock to calculate yeah i think it's not
finding the winning plan he's got a
queen now but i think this is a draw
black's king is no longer cut off yeah
definitely
yeah i mean i don't see the win to be
honest i think we need some what defense
what defense there i mean from where ye
we were saying how great magnus is
playing but wei yi just to give himself
chances has done a phenomenal job um of
of getting in defensive position but
have we started to see within the past
year perhaps a magnus sometimes getting
too pragmatic in the ending
i mean i think his endings are still i
mean the best there's ever been and uh i
i i mean i'm surprised he didn't win
this one i mean what do you think david
i mean he's too pragmatic or yeah i
think just struggling to calculate as
deeply as he maybe is used to and now
here we go the black pawn is just too
close to its promotions where white's
king is cut off as well white's king is
going to try and come back but the black
king is going to shoulder it off and by
shouldering we mean the black king will
kind of block the white king from going
towards this black pawn and this one is
dead draw now the black horn just pushes
forward
if this position with white to play
white would be winning but nope the
black king
is just in time and
here we go we're about to see a draw
yeah king versus king no way to win this
game magnus shaking his head and there
we go draw yeah
well done by you